[Music]
Trello is a visual collaboration tool
that helps people create a shared
perspective on any project whether it's
at work or at home we took the
whiteboard that you might have in your
office and the sticky note and basically
built Trello from that you can plan any
project you have by using those cards
and moving them around the board figure
out what's going on it's super important
for us to be everywhere that people are
collaborating so we had to make sure
that you had the best possible
experience that you could have on your
Android device when we first started
thinking about trouble on mobile we were
faced with a very difficult design
problem how to take something that is so
visual and convince it into a smaller
screen so you still get the same visual
overview everything that's happening
before material Trello seemed very
inconsistent it was hard to navigate
material design has really helped the
design and development process because
the guidelines are so thorough and well
thought-out you don't have to go back
and forth with developers our material
redesign has been a huge success for us
what we have seen is a 10% increase in
the number of sessions per user per week
a 42% increase in the number of boards
creative recession and most importantly
for us a 63% increase in the number of
users added to boards per session that
tells us that people are using Trello
way more than they were using it before
Trello is fun it's flexible there is so
much that you can do with it they can
plan out their meals for the week they
don't have to go to the fridge and write
down a list it's a more natural way it's
like you're talking to your spouse or
your boyfriend or your girlfriend
instead you're just telling it to your
watch and I'll put it on the Trello list
a key area where Trello really really
shines is when you use it with somebody
else material gives you a better way of
communicating one of the things that
we've seen people use Trello for is
planning marathons and they can plan
routes and they can say you know I've
done these exercises and everything it
helps the user focus on what they're
doing instead of thinking about how
they're gonna do it if I had any advice
for developers isolate what is core
about your app and then use the material
principles in the framework to come up
with a design that
that livers not to you users work with
google play because there are so many
options out there for developers and
designers after material we were able to
define trelles visual identity and
combine those things together so that we
had a clear vision of what trailer was
I'm most proud of the fact that what
we've built is loved by so many people
[Music]
you